[Applause]
seth thank you so much for doing an
under the influencer
interview with me
i would love for people to know how did
you get started i started out writing
doing like comedy writing for a card
game called what do you mean i was doing
that for about six months and being
around funny creative people like that
we
try things from time to time we decided
to hold a sign out in the street
protesting something and that day i
think it was someone's birthday in the
company and everyone was like replying
all and like racking up our emails i go
let's go protest that so i held a sign
up that said stop replying all to
company-wide emails it was a success
like people laughed people thought it
was really funny so we were like oh we
could probably keep doing this i was
like is it is it cool if i pop out of
work and just hold a sign up every day
and they're like yeah if you want to do
that that's cool like let's see if this
goes somewhere that's how it started
because it's you a cardboard sign a
giant sharpie yeah but
what you write on the signs is what's
captivated attention
when you did stop replying all the
company emails it blows up what was your
next one where did the idea come from i
really just choose kind of just based
off whether i can come up with something
i also want to make sure universally
people know what it is because if it's
like just something that's kind of
trending on like twitter america i
realized that i have fans in like
istanbul and like australia and i want
to make sure that it's like fully known
before i do it so like squid games
that's like a worldwide show right now
those usually perform the best
whatever's whatever's trending do you
know when a trend is over how do you
know it's too late move on i mean i'm
pretty
social media savvy with this job so i
can kind of see when things are
happening right now and kind of when
it's like i think that's either overdone
or not that funny or just kind of
in the past i don't think people are
really talking about it anymore i
disagree
i think what you do is not easy i do
think influencers try hard i do think
they some garner a lot of power what do
you say to those people who have
garnered a lot of power and a platform
what is your advice to them on how they
proceed with their platform
that's a really hot that's what i mean
this is a really hard because i can't
really speak on that i just have like a
concept that's very fluid and that works
for me i mean that's that's advice i
give people whenever they just are at
nothing and want to start sounding like
maybe just try a concept try this
concept and if people love it run with
it but make it different in your own way
i try to at least spice things up
sometimes sometimes i'll smile in a
picture sometimes i'll be
in a totally different place i try to
run with a concept and have some kind of
like the glasses and the you know
there's like a character i try to keep
it very consistent yeah consistent i
like hearing that your first idea wasn't
gold that you had to go through some
because i think for young minds out
there
it's nice to hear
it didn't strike immediately it took
some tries what i disagree with you
about is that your concept is simple i
think
the cleanest simple seeming concepts to
me are the hardest yeah i think
that's actually what i credit myself
most on is one just being open another
piece of advice i always give is like
for one i'm not an advice giver but
something i tell people is like don't be
afraid of looking stupid i posted
probably like 10 signs before
you know i only had probably like 2 000
followers and they were just like my
friends so i was just posting signs and
it got
weird to a point like people would walk
by and be like
what is this guy doing this is and i
would it kind of would make me doubt it
kind of like that's not that funny like
yeah after like the 10th one bigger
pages started reposting it and now i'm
so happy that i didn't give up give up
and think that that was you know just a
dumb idea
and be vulnerable it's okay ride the
crest of the wave be uncomfortable
vulnerable's great okay if you weren't
doing this
what would your fantasy other life be
well
i've actually really always wanted to do
acting i've always wanted to like try
being in a movie i just think that would
be so cool to see at least at least to
try i also stand up comedy was another
one that i always wanted to try which
i've done it a couple times and don't
know if that's right for me now did you
go to like an open mic yeah i was really
happy to try it it was very
how was it i think it went well i had
like girls coming up to me after like oh
that's like you were the funniest one
you were my favorite one of the night
and i'd be like oh my god
i still don't know i think i'm still
trying to to figure it out maybe i'll
become an entrepreneur and make a
product well you're certainly starting
from an amazing place yeah very lucky
very blessed
i am one of your biggest fans in a long
line of many people and thank you for
these words of wisdom they are
definitely going to connect with people
and social media
is the wild wild west finding its way
and giving so many opportunities to
people
thank you so much thank you very much
[Music]
you